benvenuti solito i nuovissimi scarti
cari dice tu per tu guardi volte troppo
titoli della serie scherzi alla maestra
cattiva come sempre lasciate un bel mi
piace
se non avete visto gli episodi
precedenti andrade amore potete vederli
qui tutto video anche sul canale
digitale si lascia tu mi piace l'ho già
detto lasciatemi un altro club carlo
metodi rigoni iniziamo subito per il
primo test notiamo con questo scherzo in
cui se un gorilla usa la pozione d'amore
di scary teacher o per riunirla con il
suo vero unico grande sarà il suo unico
grande amore mai dovrebbe essere il suo
fidanzato francis quindi che riti c'era
è diventata tipo una strega sta facendo
le sue pozioni e ha detto la mia
creazione sta provando a creare una
pozione d'amore per fare innamorare
francis anche se pensavo che francis
posteggia innamorassi infatti sorge la
sopporto forse si sta lentamente
rendendo conto che scheri teacher non è
quello che sembra molto cattiva e quindi
si sta disamorando li sta facendo la
pozione per tenerlo sempre per bene
allora si è scritto che dobbiamo
trasformare la pozione di scary teaser
la pozione d'amore in una pozione per
animali in una pozione d'amore per
animali
ecco forse cosa c'entrava il gorilla ma
perché la facciamo il numerone di un
gorilla oppure trasformiamo lei ho presi
se non gorilla sarebbe molto divertente
ecco cosa abbiamo qui il libro delle
pozzo che salendo su adesso dalle scale
attento massimo scappa scappa si sta
rincorrendo che abbiamo dobbiamo
scappare davis intima aiuto no sta
scendendo le scale detto ok che prima
della fine
questo tanto wow guardate se bisogna
stare molto attenti alle mesi fa melina
guardiamo sempre la camera acqua metti
il libro delle pulsioni sitri kassid
zanaboni qui credo che si vuole
dell'acido citrico e del liquido
infiammate
limone liquido infiammabile liquido
infiammabile ce l'abbiamo
benissimo anche a prendere qualcosa
della cucina adesso a tentativi sto
uscendo forza si facciamo riuscita via
libera controlla quella bottiglietta
queste sale questa gianna salsa deciso
ma la nostra limone perché lui mi dice
di estrarre il succo veri amici
serve uno spremiagrumi eccola qua è
bello caspita che bel frullato ora si
tratta abbiano missiva anche la passata
per berg
una forza che non ha funzionato certi
bicchiere a bravo lo sta a lei al piano
di sotto
bravissimo allora lei e io ho tremato
sopra dovrebbe essere al piano di sopra
perché il pavimento è diverso da
scendendo giù però in centro tramite il
passaggio segreto è che noi siamo già
pronti
ok allora mettiamo prima era prima ma
simile è meglio minardi niente deve poi
la benzina non vedere cosa fare a questa
frazione che dovrebbe aver funzionato
sì abbiamo fatto tutto quello che ci
credeva
[Musica]
di olim girino
abbiamo fatto per la pozione per gli
animali era la pozione d'amore per
l'anima quindi è arrivato un gorilla che
si innamora conto che di fincher in più
teneva lontano il fidanzato francis
vittima che sia bravissimo scherzo
script incertezza che pensa che
sorprenderà i giudici del suo concorso
di bellezza
quindi tu prova a farla scoppiare invece
guarda che poverino
come stai prestiti sorpreso di essere la
più bella del mondo anzi dell'universo
perché lei vuole diventare ha visto
diverse e che il vestito era carino però
non aggiusta lei fa era carina ma ha
fatto santo rita da invece come si
comportava ma poi questo per mantenere
tratta male il povero francis anche
tanto povero a una me perché è cattivo
anche lui in italia già preso questo che
c'era una bombola di aerei o quindi
ma forse la faremo davvero soffiare
quindi lei scritti giuramento che 40 c è
il palco ha detto che farà questa gara
di bellezza e quindi è l'occasione
perfetta per rovinargli le fargli un
bellissimo scherzo non bisogna farsi
vedere neanche da francis altrimenti
avremmo fallito che dietro l'altro ecco
l'ho detto io mandare siamo sul palco
non si può sapere saltare faccia da
sauna possa dire con le stelle sopra la
stavano c'è una porta qui guarda
quest'anno porta un passaggio segreto
bravo che qui c'è un tubo la mettiamo
delio
tocca primi ep vestiti di share con il
gas già fatto guardo
[Musica]
tommy palloncino a volte come un
palloncino e poi si sdoppia tesi esposta
ha ricordato un film ma non vi dico
quale dovete voi indovinare nei commenti
che scena di quale film di ari corato
questo scherzo è molto simile alla scena
di un film molto famoso e molto perché
lo chiuderà super divertente questo
scherzo era super facile davvero siamo
ora a uno scherzo di natale molto bella
ma il peggior skater di sempre
aiutiamo scheri teacher aiutiamo a
rompere le speranze di scritti share nel
diventare una professionista nel
pattinaggio sul ghiaccio vicino
praticamente la piscina si è ghiacciata
congelata per i lei vuole fare
pattinaggio sul ghiaccio nella piscina
quindi questo mi fa pensare già a come
potrebbe forse la faremo cadere dentro
la piscina romperemo il gas
vediamo cosa possiamo mai preso bella
non c'è nessuna decorazioni natalizie
che strano forse ci sono
altre scherzi non le ha ancora messo
buona torta
ma ti sembra il momento si faccia vista
davanti al camino spenta ti mette
davanti al camino spento si scalda
tirarglielo la torta in testa
purtroppo sento era scappato via
lo ha detto io ti puri o come un ragazzo
abbia giocato il sale però penso che lei
abbia arrivano in quota arrivando tra
l'altro non sta uscendo sociale perché
con le sale sciogliamo chiediamo il
viaggio non proprio lì noi dobbiamo
uscire il recco ma tu stai attenta
tiratina la torta giusto in tempo in
faccia eccolo no perché si sentono tutto
che allora guarda sul tavolo se lo vorrà
vista dal marocco la brocca ametista le
di grassi e così noi non riusciamo a
spargerlo meglio sulla piscina
6 dove e in cucina e l'infinito ti
facciamo scappare volta mi sono
incastrato no caro di nuova finestra
la mostra come ho fatto di castrare ok
ora dobbiamo solo andare nella piscina e
rompere in piazza grazie a chi non vede
l'ora di vedere scheri di turchi che
circa grosso fra c'è dentro
scusami scappare guardiamo la donna
sopra dell'assessore ma si può fare
così ci godiamo lo spettacolo aspettiamo
ora che rispondiamo misti e sta uscendo
che bello spiarla dal quale non si
accorga
cosa si è arrivata eccola questo di
vertice allora il prossimo certo
riguarda dei topi perché spiriti c'era
paura dei topi quindi dobbiamo insomma
farli una scherza con i topi dice topi
state lontani dalla mia buonissima torna
ci ricordiamo se fosse spesso l'abbiamo
già fatto forse l'anno scorso no quindi
andiamo comunque a rifarlo ma se voi vi
ricordate se l'abbiamo fatto
scrivetecelo comunque nei commenti
dobbiamo trovare un topo
lei sta già entrando in cugino uffa che
vediamo il che nello sgabuzzino
sicuramente si sarà qualche tocco facile
possiamo prendere marco lento eccoli
sono tanti forse bisognerà prendere
e la frase fuori ma lì cosa sta facendo
sta mettendo olio di cocco mettendo
sopra la torta che sembrano trovato una
ciotola tipo vitale ha trovato la
trappola
dobbiamo scendere in cucina adesso che
si sposta lei lei ha preso lo zucchero
sta proprio completando la sua volta che
lo sta facendo nel salotto la porta non
capisco perché ho sofferto per noi che
ci sia una mostra rapirti e li sta
continuando la sua preparazione con lo
zucchero
ma scendiamo in italia ingiunge una sola
delle ricette io mi domando guardava
camera il nostro premio di formaggio che
ha visto non mi ricordava anche formale
eccolo eccolo il cross ma ancora davanti
bravo a scappare da star ha non ricordo
[Musica]
baggio il capo o che li sta arrivando
quale stampa iafano passato nella cucina
ok nello sgabuzzino via via mi bravo
allora adesso dobbiamo mettere il
formaggio questo bambino è un po la
solitaire maggio bravo abbiamo che lei
non arrivi quali mosca pechino andò
frodo pronto le nozioni nei fili fatta a
prendere cose poi torna nel di male
vedevo cover e aggiungeva allora va bene
ok bene trappole o no no no no no
ricordo a meno male se mancato
pochissimo
ora dobbiamo decidere dove mettere i
topi per spaventare la gente li sta
facendo la torta forse bisognerà
metterli in cucina andiamo in cucina
penso che anche lei sta andando il
pugile adesso per me non salendo le
scale perfetto lui andò best
cosa faccio un po paura a credere di
come si invita l'amico i topi nel forno
sventola verini così le cose andavano a
mettere la torta si spaventava valle
siccome non hai richiuso la porta del
forno nessuna corte ha sparato sullo
stop abbiamo fallito l'ultimo scherzo
però gli altri sono stati super super di
latte di ballo è stato il tuo preferito
allora il mio preferito è stato quella
che l'abbiamo gonfiato di abbiamo
gonfiato il vestito colleghi e tu quale
quella del gorilla è stato super
divertente feriti sensibili fiori con
una funzione ovvero non mi piace se
volete che riproviamo questa scherza
magari riusciamo a completarla e ora mi
lasciavo pa4 casellina cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite
buona visione ciao